this is parkour internet sensation of
2004 and it was in Milan the Bond films
it's pretty impressive the goal is to
get from point A to point B as
creatively as possible so technically
they are doing parkour as long as the
point a is dilution and point B is okay
we all go together or we go one at a
time here it is here it is truck two
refrigerators two dumpster 360 spin onto
the palace
backflip gainer into the trash hardcore
parkour
so do you recognize any of these men I
was hiding in the bathroom stall so I
didn't see his face
but I heard him he was singing along to
the music at the bar do you remember
what he was singing I think it was that
song I want it that way
Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay number
one could you please sing the opening
two I want it that way
really okay you are my fire number two
keep it going
the one desire
number three believe when I say number
four I want it that way tell me why
ain't nothin but tell me why ain't
nothin but a mistake number five I never
wanna he say
Oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
god I forgot about that part this is
going to be a very good year very good
Jan is at home Jim is back my protege
Ryan is a corporate good stuff Andy and
Dwight are rocking the sales team I feel
very blessed
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to answer an age-old question
right
what's Amy's deal she's single no we're
dating come on the question is who here
does the best impression of captain
Raymond Holt you'll be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
captain Holt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the whole table
begin
what is this gluttonous monstrosity
before me sugar and this is quite sweet
that's your Holt impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it
classical music what's going on here
what are you doing captain hey nothing
just eating some marshmallows care for
one mr. Milo I know it don't know I
don't know what you should probably just
meander back there take a look see he's
if he's back dare I you know what I'm
going to for old times sake
great practical joke Jim got me go to
the annex no God no God please no no no
no hey there boy how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really
sorry to hear that man yeah bullets over
Broadway was on TV I came down with a
big old Dianne Wiest infection
like ye it's kind of blurry it's better
question what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets Battlestar Galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of $11 you know
what imitation is the most sincere form
of flattery so I thank you energy theft
is not a joke Jim millions of families
suffer every year Michael oh that's
funny Michael
interesting
very very interesting
guys captain Holt has no pants on Oh
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts at 11:55 a.m. captain Holt
walked past us holding a hot bowl of
soup at 12:03 p.m. I heard him yell out
then at 12:07 he called Gina into his
honest she entered holding nothing one
minute later she left holding an opaque
bag captain Holt's pants were in that
bag his knees are in the breeze he's in
his undies that evidence is
circumstantial oh so you guys want
visual confirmation no really
done hey captain I just need you to sign
something at my desk real quick just
leave it on the couch dismissed okay sir
you're gonna freak yo-yo ma is in the
precinct and he's giving out autographs
yo-yo Ma's on tour in Australia right
now how do you know that hey amaze you
another bowl of soup since you spilled
yours earlier but you're gonna have to
come over here to get it
alright parole comes to be wasting time
so yes I spilled some minestrone on my
pants and I'm sitting in my underwear
happy yes sir I need you to sign off on
look at us just three people with pants
on having a normal conversation yep
no story here coat Michael just rented
The Devil Wears Prada
he has his Netflix sent here to the
office and he watches them in pieces
when things are slow steak where's my
steak he's a big Meryl Streep fan so I
shouldn't be surprised that he's
identified with her character didn't me
Armani a suit on the fall and like the
main company number cuz I'm gonna have
to call it from where's Armani he's on
the phone too slow you're not going to
Paris I'm so much better than you
I owe you an apology you finished the
movie yeah was awesome
big surprise ending will ruin it for you
no go ahead
Meryl Streep is the bad guy you never
see it coming
anyway if I was mean in any way to you
I'm sorry I just want what's best for
you a manouschka
macushla he's watching Million Dollar
Baby he's gonna try to kill me hey JC
the place on the corner of serving
lemonade and he had to keep the jar it's
pretty cool yes that's very cool Scully
mmm will you excuse me just one moment
oh sure guys guys guys Scully has a
mason jar full of lemonade you called us
in here to tell us that no I called you
in here to change your lives for you see
a mere five minutes ago Hitchcock
introduced me to his new goldfish who
lives in Oh identical mason jar oh this
isn't gonna end well there are two
possible outcomes and we're gonna bet on
which one happens first so will
Hitchcock put fish food in Scully's
lemonade or will Scully drink
Hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
dr. strike is on fish what
you